can we give those four guys credit the
four guys the four dudes running around
doing my imitations are killing it
they're making money those are so funny
dudes the imitations are killing me oh
the guys that imitate you yeah they're
on fire yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm so
i'm it's
out of all the things in my career that
have ever happened that may be top ten
of happiness for me the fact that people
bring them to the conference
maybe
they have to perform at vcom maybe
we'll see if they get [ __ ] yeah
this guy the best one
is he the best impersonator this guy's a
[ __ ] beast
what's your question my man
all right so basically i'm getting now
to get into public speaking like how
you house in the united states of
calling
are
america okay
giving them public speaking tips in
their bathroom
shower
[ __ ] [ __ ] garage yeah in the
garage
i was eating [ __ ] for like 17 years too
many tips for free okay
i think it's a good idea to call every
single house in america yeah like are
you making this nft
i'm not making this okay
garage sales
pause
i once read that you said that only fans
is a garage sale for [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you didn't make ghosts though no but
that's how you said that's what history
will say history you said history will
say that nfts are garage sales [ __ ] not
your quote no i wouldn't use that word
huh
vagina
[Laughter]
what do you garyvee
listen i think i think uh
i think that um
i want to go back to that real quick
yeah
what gets crazy so when you build i i
grew up thinking i was gonna build
businesses yeah i also had the greatest
i have the greatest mother of all time
who like really
i mean it's actually insane how much
you know the game of dna
environment and who's building you just
fascinates the [ __ ] out of me because it
just does right you see like
siblings twins same household uh lots of
the same situations but a parent died
along the way wealth not wealth
i i had the great fortune of having
a framework that i think is remarkable
which is
not having anything
but having lots of happiness in the home
i believe the people that when i look at
the world 30 40 50 60 year olds that if
you show me someone who didn't grow up
with a whole lot but the family was
happy as [ __ ] inside those four walls
i'll show you somebody who's just
winning in life it doesn't mean that
they're making the most maybe that's not
their dna so i had that great fortune
and so when i was 13 16 when i was like
i'm gonna build businesses i always knew
i was gonna be a businessman because of
the way my mom parented me i also
thought about things like and it's gonna
be like i thought things as a kid that
i'm very proud of like and it's gonna be
awesome because i'm gonna put a lot of
people on like i'm gonna have 30 000
employees and they're going to do good
and that's like a residual like
what i never saw was people doing things
that were going to get benefit from me
living my life as a person
like i've been following all three four
of the impersonators pretty carefully
like a lot of good stuff's happening for
them
they're they're getting more shows more
money more opportunity that's just
amazing and i think more people should
be thinking about
what's the collateral of their success
there are kids literally literally that
are going to have professional
comedy based careers because they're
watching you right now at 12. that's
cool
richard pryor macho man randy savage 100
100 not 99 have an impact to why i had a
good public speaking career when i came
out the gate and i started talking about
business
i didn't do [ __ ] decks like everybody
i [ __ ] did
like off-the-cuff
stand-up slash wrestling promo talk and
that was unique and it put me on yeah
that like that's happening every day and
i wish that more people that are making
doing
actually thought about what the residual
was of what they're doing and i think
that actually might make them a tweak
more thoughtful that may create more
good guys that clip is brought to you by
blue chew the makers of hard dicks and
happy wives that's right your girl
deserves it even your side chick
deserves your best and the way you're
gonna deliver it to her is getting on
that chew same active ingredients it's
inside cialis or viagra but this is the
chew this is the one we rock with and
this is the one that we do spinal damage
to the ones we love with
make sure
you get your first month free by going
to bluechew.com
and use the promo code andrew you just
gotta pay five dollar ship and that's it
thank you so much for watching the clips
keep supporting the podcast we'll see
you soon
you